[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC ROSEBAUM: Hi, I'm Eric.
YOTAM MANN: Hi, I'm Yotam.
With machine learning, you
can now take a picture,
and have a computer tell
you exactly what it sees.
AI: Eyewear,
glasses, vision care.
ERIC ROSEBAUM: We wanted to see
if we could do something fun
with this, and we had an idea.
What if the computer
turned the things that it
saw into lyrics of a song?
It could even rhyme about them.
AI: We've got
glasses in this spot.
Could be eyewear, but maybe not.
YOTAM MANN: There are two
parts, image recognition,
for seeing things, and speech
synthesis, for talking.
AI: Hello.
ERIC ROSEBAUM: For
image recognition,
we use the Cloud Vision API.
You can just send
it a picture, and it
returns labels for
what it sees, along
with the confidence scores.
It started really
getting fun when
we brought in a song made by one
of our musical heroes, Giorgio
Moroder.
AI: Yeah, all right.
YOTAM MANN: And for
the computer's voice,
we used an open source project
called Mary TTS, combined
with the Web Audio API.
This let us add effects
to the computer's voice,
and sync it to the beat.
AI: We've got glasses in
this spot-ot-ot-ot-ot.
YOTAM MANN: We had our
friends try it out.
And they had a lot
of fun pointing it
at all kinds of things.
AI: Is that food
I see-see-see-see?
SPEAKER 1: That's pretty close.
SPEAKER 2: Play it to me.
AI: That's plucked
string instruments
on my screen-screen-screen.
Could be profession,
but maybe not-not-not.
Looks like world to me-me-me.
Digging that camera operator
you've got-got-got-got.
SPEAKER 1: Digging
that camera operator.
ERIC ROSEBAUM: We
call it Giorgio Cam.
And it's just one example
of how you can use
machine learning in fun ways.
You can play with it and get
the code at g.co/aiexperiments.